-After the melodrama
over the suspected
Chinese spy balloon a week ago,
the U.S. has now shot down
three more unidentified objects
over North America that,
the White House said,
pose very real threats
to air traffic,
leading to wild speculation
about what those objects
could be
and, of course, criticism
from Republicans,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Okay, guys, something very weird
is going on
[ Laughter ]
and, no, I'm not talking
about those ads for Jesus
during the Super Bowl.
[ Laughter ]
Jesus doesn't need to advertise
during the Super Bowl.
The guy gave one sermon,
on a mount, 2,000 years ago
and everybody's still talking
about it.
[ Laughter ]
You know who should charge
$7 million for a 30-second spot?
Mounts.
[ Laughter ]
Also, please don't tell --
Also, please don't tell me
Jesus was advertising
his new streaming service
because I'm not sure
I can afford to get Messiah+
[ Laughter and applause ]
while, at the same time,
I'm worried that I can't afford
not to.
[ Laughter ]
Now -- Plus,
now is not a good time
to launch a new streamer,
especially since you're going
to have to compete
with Satan's streaming service,
Tubi. Only
[ Laughter ]
the devil himself
would think it's a good idea
to spend millions of dollars
to trick me into thinking
I sat on my remote.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Incidentally, the group that ran
those Jesus ads is tied
to efforts to curb LGBTQ rights
and ban medication abortion,
so, I guess, when they say...
the "us" has a big
old asterisk on it.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the weird thing
that's been happening is
the skies over America
are suddenly turning
into that carnival game
Balloon Pop.
[ Laughter ]
Three mysterious objects have
been identified and shot down
over North American airspace
in as many days
and officials have
many more theories
than answers
about what's going on.
-The U.S. military shooting down
three mysterious flying objects
in just three days
and now the White House is
under growing pressure
to answer
some basic questions --
what are they,
where do they come from,
were these Chinese spy drones
or something else?
-U.S. officials described it
as an...
and its...
While it wasn't considered
a military threat,
the Pentagon says it had...
...and a top general says
they're considering all options.
-Not even the pilots,
apparently,
were really able to identify
what they saw.
Those pilots, we have learned,
have given very
conflicting accounts
of what they
actually experienced,
with some pilots saying
that the object interfered
with the plane's sensors;
other pilots saying that they
didn't really experience that;
other pilots saying that,
when they looked at the object,
they could identify no
identifiable propulsion system.
-Okay, wait, I'm sorry.
It was octagonal,
it had strings hanging off it,
[ Laughter ]
it it had no identifiable
propulsion system,
and it interfered
with the plane's sensors?
That sounds like what a stoner
who didn't see a UFO...
[ Laughter ]
...would describe it as.
"There were strings."
[ Laughter ]
As far as I can tell, there are
three possibilities here --
it's a foreign adversary spying
on us, it's aliens,
or there's a dude in Montana
with a remote control
in his hands, absolutely
[bleep] his pants right now.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, honey, you have fun
flying your new drone?"
Actually, dear,
I realized that you were right
and it is a dumb hobby,
so, I sold it.
I sold it last week, in fact.
Also, if anyone from the FBI
knocks on the door,
tell them you saw aliens
in the sky!
[ Laughter and applause ]
The details of what pilots
have seen in the skies
above North America
are just downright bizarre.
For example...
I swear to God, if this is
a viral marketing campaign
[ Laughter ]
for a Herbie the Love Bug
reboot,
I am going to be psyched!
[ Laughter ]
I love me some Herbie.
Sue me.
[ Laughter ]
But I actually think
the Volkswagen comparison
is a good thing.
There's no better sign
aliens come in peace
than showing up
in a Volkswagen Bug.
[ Laughter ]
They're probably hippie aliens
and long white ponytails.
[ Laughter ]
And, if we talked to them,
they'd say --
[ Surfer voice ]
Hey, man, we're here to teach
you a new way to make water.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But do we listen?
No!
We just blow them
out of the sky
while they utter
their final words --
[ Surfer voice ]
Bummer, man!
[ Laughter ]
We were going to bring
the glaciers back.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, the Air Force general
who's in charge of NORAD,
the military organization
that protects American
and Canadian skies,
specifically, would not rule out
aliens when directly asked.
-"Thanks"?
[ Laughter ]
Who -- I'm sorry,
the general in charge
of North American
Aerospace Defense
says there might be aliens
flying above us
and there are just
no follow-up questions?
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, some people are saying
that the aliens are here
and they intend
to enslave us underground
and steal our women.
I'm not ruling anything out."
Cool.
Thanks!
[ Laughter ]
That's how exhausted
journalists are
from the past eight years
of nonstop crisis --
psychotic president,
attempted coup,
land war in Europe,
and a global pandemic.
We hear about aliens
and we're all just like,
"Alright, well, let us know
if the situation changes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How much time we'd have
to evacuate and whatnot.
I mean, sure would like it
to make it to the season finale
of "Love Island"
before the old
wah wah wah wah, pkkkh!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, it turns out
there's actually
a much more mundane
potential explanation
for why we're suddenly
finding more random stuff
floating in the skies above us.
After the Chinese spy balloon,
the military basically widened
their antenna
to identify more objects
than they usually would.
According
to The Washington Post...
"Also, if you're thinking
about buying a car,
maybe wait a few weeks because,
based on what these objects
turn out to be,
our roads may be obliterated."
[ Laughter ]
Thanks!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Although, personally,
I would like to know
why are there filters,
in the first place?
Shouldn't NORAD be able
to detect abnormal objects
with surveillance capabilities?
How many of these
have we missed, so far?
I mean, on one hand,
the explanation is a relief.
On the other hand,
it feels like they're saying,
"Don't freak out about this.
They've been
in the skies forever.
We just didn't notice them.
Be they from China or outer
space, one thing is clear --
they know every single [bleep]
thing about us by now."
[ Laughter ]
So, obviously, it seems like
there are, very likely,
some less dramatic explanations
for the strange activity.
NORAD widened its filters,
so, it's just detecting
more air traffic than usual.
Or maybe it's a foreign
adversary spying on us
in the way that all global
superpowers spy on each other.
And maybe it's aliens. I mean,
it can't be a coincidence
this happened the same week
Senator Rick Scott was
in the news...
[ Laughter ]
...for trying
to cut Social Security.
[ Changes voice ]
Mother ship,
I need a distraction.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Release the Volkswagens.
[ Laughter ]
But I got to say -- I never
thought I would say this --
This is one time I kind of wish
Donald Trump
was still president,
just for like one hour,
[ Laughter ]
because, if it was aliens,
he would blurt it out instantly.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, can you
imagine the tweet?
Everyone'd be like,
"Is it Russia? Is it China?"
And Trump would be like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, I would give --
I would give anything
to hear Donald Trump say
the word extraterrestrial.
[ Laughter ]
He'd do that thing
where he says it wrong
and, instead
of correcting himself,
he would just say it right,
like both are acceptable.
[ As Trump ]
The viderers -- the visitors
[ Laughter ]
are extraterrustrial
and extraterrestrial.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If aliens are here
and we're [bleep], either way,
[ Laughter ]
just give me --
just give me the Trump speech.
[ As Trump ]
Good evening,
my fellow Americans --
although, we won't be Americans
for long, I can't imagine.
I can't imagine maps are going
to be much --
mean much in a couple of hours.
[ Laughter ]
I come to you tonight
to say we've made contact
with some extra--
Ooh.
Extra bad guys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're from space.
They're extra bad
and they're not like
"Star Wars" aliens.
And I would know, because I
visited Skywalker Ranch.
[ Laughter ]
1982, I was with George Lucas
and his little trash can,
R2-MeToo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And this very little guy came
up to me,
walking up to me,
tough guy, strong guy,
[ Laughter ]
tears pouring
down his furry face,
and he said to me -- I said --
I'll never forget what he said.
He said, "Mr. Trump, sir,
yub nub."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Today, White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean-Pierre
declared that it is
almost certainly not aliens.
-There is no --
again, no indication of aliens
or extraterrestrial activity
[ Laughter ]
with these recent takedowns.
-Okay, but that's definitely
what the White House would say
in a movie
about an alien invasion.
[ Laughter ]
Thirty minutes later,
cut to Joe Biden
personally fighting an alien
on the roof of the White House.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It would give Biden a chance
to utter one
of those iconic
movie president lines.
[ As Biden ]
Get off my stairs!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Surfer voice ]
Hey, man! Cut it out!
[ Laughter ]
We were trying to bring back
the polar bears.
[ Laughter ]
So, the U.S. Air Force
has shot down
three identified objects
in as many days,
which, by the way, was exactly
what Republicans demanded
when the Chinese
spy balloon floated
across American airspace
for a few days.
They wanted it shot down
immediately.
So, I guess, now that Biden
is taking their advice,
they're going to line up
to congratulate him.
And I'm just kidding.
They're whining, yet again.
[ Laughter ]
-The American people
have seen Joe Biden
in the first two years.
He has failed to secure
the southern border.
Now, they're beginning
to get concerned
that he can't secure
our airspace.
-It's a whole bunch
of radio silence,
tap dancing, and equivocation
from the Biden administration.
You know,
we shouldn't be surprised.
Things have been a disaster
since they took control
two years ago.
-This administration
is refusing
to say
what is happening.
What are these objects?
What are these crafts?
Who is directing them?
How are they getting here?
What is their mission?
-I think it shows our lack
of transparency
by this administration.
You know, the first balloon,
they shot down after it had
transversed
our entire country.
They claimed it was for safety.
And, obviously, they could've
dropped the thing in Montana.
They would --
They're more likely
to hit some guy
with a mullet and a tank top
on Myrtle Beach
[ Laughter ]
than they were to hit
somebody in Montana.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, first of all,
if a guy with a mullet
and a tank top on Myrtle Beach
did get hit with a UFO,
I'm pretty sure that dude would
be [bleep] thrilled.
[ Laughter ]
[ Southern accent ]
Whoa! All my exes
are finally gonna believe me!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Barbara, it's Jared.
Yo, did you see me on the news?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Who's laughing now, Barbara?
[ Laughter ]
Why is Stephen Miller on TV
talking about this,
or any subject?
He sounds like the guy
from the sci-fi movie
who would be in the Oval Office,
telling the president
to nuke the aliens immediately,
while a bunch of scientists beg
for more time.
[ As Miller ]
We must nuke this unidentified
aircraft immediately,
in order to establish
American sovereignty
and superiority
over our airspace.
"Sir, we're pretty sure
it's just a birthday balloon.
It has a Paw Patrol on it."
[ Laughter ]
We must show the Paw Patrol
that they are not the law
in this country. We are!
[ Laughter ]
The White House held a briefing
to offer more details today.
But I will say, I wouldn't mind
hearing a little more
from Biden.
When he was asked
at the White House
about the object shot down
over Alaska,
this is all he had to say.
[ Laughter ]
That's it?
Can you give us
a little more info?
Unidentified objects are
getting shot down in the skies
above the U.S.,
like a game of Duck Hunt,
and Biden's playing it close
to the vest,
like a grandpa
at a family reunion
when grandma's recounting
how they met.
"You know, your grandfather was
quite the Casanova
back in the day.
He took me out to Lovers' Cliff
in his Stingray."
[ As Biden ]
Hey! That's not
for them to hear.
Let's just say
it was a success.
[ Laughter ]
The lack of concrete information
has left a vacuum
for conspiracy nuts to run wild.
For example, over the weekend,
Earth's Marjorie Taylor Greene
[ Laughter ]
listed off a bunch
of insane hypotheticals
for what could've been
inside the Chinese spy balloon
and recounted yelling
at military officials
during a congressional briefing
about it.
-You sat by and allowed
this Chinese spy balloon,
that could've contained
-Yep.
-a bioweapon, like COVID.
-That's right.
-It could've contained
a nuclear bomb,
an EMP attack,
or hypersonic missiles.
I said, "You allowed this
to go across the country
and then you want
to stand up here
and give us our excuses --
your excuses --
on why you didn't shoot it down
because you're
gathering intelligence
or you didn't want to risk
endangering anyone's lives?"
I said, "That is the biggest
bunch of bull[bleep]."
-Yeah! The balloon could've
contained a nuclear bomb,
which is why you should've
shot a missile at it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone knows that's how you
safely disarm a nuclear weapon
directly above a densely
populated area.
[ Laughter ]
Missiles cancel out
nuclear bombs,
just like the reverse card
in UNO.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What else does she think
could've been
inside this balloon?
[ As Greene ]
There could've been bioweapons,
missiles, a nuclear weapon;
or, even worse,
a bunch of middle school
textbooks
that teach accurate history!
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, it's a mysterious situation.
We don't have any details.
There's a bunch
of possible explanations.
It's obviously quite unlikely
that it's aliens,
although, if it is aliens,
Republicans want them
shot down immediately,
even if it means they land
on a farm in Montana,
in the middle of a...
-Bunch of bull[bleep].
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]